[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance of all the Trump problems
this perhaps is the least important but
perhaps the most symbolic it is from his
New Year's Eve dinner
525 dollars a ticket for members 575 for
the unwashed hoi polloi ad what's it
called sloppy joes what's the name mera
Lago at which Trump got to practice his
pay-for-play skills before assuming
office and he got up and gave a speech
and name-checked is Dubai billionaire
business partner friend and as the old
visual quiz tag line goes how many
things are wrong with this picture but
the symbolism actually pertained to
another guest who showed up in a video
of the party obtained by the Palm Beach
Daily News which you can see on their
website and if Trump's for profit event
had been carried live the narration
might have sounded something like this
and here he is the president-elect
flanked by on the left a man holding a
bird trophy clearly too heavy and
awkward for him and on Trump's right of
course that's the famed New York
businessman Joey no socks Joey no socks
now that's not his real name he's
actually Joseph Cinque spelled CIN qu e
and to explain who those who might be
considered unfriendly to him think he is
let me just read directly from a profile
of him from New York magazine from April
17 1995 quote if you believe the New
York District Attorney and other law
enforcement sources an ex-girlfriend and
several of his former friends Joe Cinque
is a small-time mobster a scam artist
and an art fence still quoting Joey no
socks who used to be friends with John
Gotti pulled up his shirt to show me
these scars from an incident 15 years
ago when he was shot three times and
left for dead though Cinque insisted the
attack was a quote robbery officials say
it was more likely a hit New York
magazine April 17 1995 and quote Joey no
socks on the right of the stage there
next to Donny no ethics now there's a
different biography of mr. Cinque his
attorney sent a letter to the folks at
BuzzFeed
mr. ching-kuo is not and never was a
friend of John Gotti nor does he now
have nor ever have had a relationship
with the quote mob and the nickname mr.
Cinque was extremely poor as a young
child in the Bronx and ran around not
only without socks but often without
shoes too more recently Joey no socks
has been running an outfit that gives
awards to hotels and such
oddly enough to Trump hotels and such
reportedly 17 awards so far Trump has
been listed as one of the group's
ambassadors extraordinaire and Joey no
Sox's honorary board has consisted of
Trump pals and Trump business associates
and Trump children at eight years ago
Trump appeared in a promotional video
for Joey no socks and the year before at
Trump's Miss Universe pageant 2008 two
of the judges were Donald Trump jr. and
Joey no socks at at Trump's 59th
birthday party in Atlantic City back
before Trump ran that place into the
ground who did Trump name check to the
crowd but Joey no socks and last May
Yahoo News quoted from an article since
evidently deleted from the website of
[ __ ] ways organization the American
Academy of hospitality Sciences quote
Joseph chin Quaid president of the aah s
has been attending mr. Trump's party for
the past 16 years it is somewhat of a
New Year's Eve tradition for him and of
course he has become dear friends with
the Trump family end quote
so naturally last spring when reporters
wondered if maybe there was something
ask you about potentially electing a
president who has had a relationship
with a guy named Joey no socks for at
least 16 years
Trump denied knowing much about no socks
or his past quote the guy's going to
give you an award you take it you don't
tend to look up his whole life story I
mean I receive awards from different
places sometimes but I'm not involved in
it how am i involved in it he may have
set up a board of trustees I don't know
I don't know that my sons are involved
with that actually but he's a very nice
man I don't know well I don't know him
well but I have found him over the years
to be a very nice man you just take the
award and not ask any questions not even
is that really why they call you Joey no
socks and then you imply that you don't
know them all that well and then 21 days
before you get sworn in as president you
have
then next you at a party which you sold
tickets to the public and you have your
transition team tell CNN quote mr. Trump
never denied knowing mr. Cinque
that's mr. no socks to you so it's all
good fun and alarming and an exciting
scary gosh I used to really enjoy The
Sopranos kind of way and it made me
think about how my late dad the
architect used to tell me that the last
thing that got built in New York City
without the mob was the hut in which the
Native Americans sold Manhattan to the
Dutch West India Company in 1626 it's
all a lot of fun until you look at that
Palm Beach Daily News picture again from
21 days before a presidential
inauguration left guy with bird statue
Center guy elected president under
really dubious circumstances right Joey
no socks seriously no this is fine
resist peace